brian pace the bears general manager met
with reporters on friday virtually and
explained that with the addition of
quarterback nick foles it's exactly what
we talked about from the start we want
to create competition we've talked to
both players and it's an open
competition that's a far cry from the
comments that were made by pace earlier
this year that mitchell trubisky is
their guy for 2020. he's only their guy
if he beats out nick falls chris we look
i
i don't think we should be surprised by
this they traded for nick foles contract
he's making more money than trubisky at
a minimum it's an open competition
at most it's false job and trubisky has
to take it from him
i agreed
to me it's false in the lead for sure
without a doubt i mean first off you
know the bears fans everybody that's
associated with the bears i mean there's
just going to be anarchy mitchell
trubisky's become a lightning rod
conversation for that fan base you know
they look at him as being the downfall
of the football team and of course you
know nobody can get over the fact that
he was drafted before watson and mahomes
and i get all of that but yeah as it
sits here right now mike i mean
if trubisky beats out nick foles
and it's not just absolutely he's
playing phenomenal in the preseason and
folz is playing horrible you know people
are going to be like what we're starting
trubisky they almost have to start falls
and let him fail
then to bring trubisky back into the
fold i think if they started trubisky to
start the season or or you know like
that way it's it's going to be anarchy
people aren't going to like it and it's
going to put tremendous pressure on
trubisky because every time he makes one
little mistake people are going to go up
get him out let's get nick foles in so i
do i'm with you i feel like they're
almost forced to give nick foles the
advantage in this situation
and even though foles is the newcomer he
has exactly the same amount of
experience now with coach matt nagy as
trubisky does two years 2012 now negi
was far from the head coach in
philadelphia in 2012 but they were
together there and they were together in
2016 when negi was the offensive
coordinator of the kansas city chiefs
and foles was drafted
by andy reid specifically to run the
system
that naggy is running and trubisky has
been the square peg in the round hole
for two years that's another advantage
for nick foles chris
yes it definitely is i mean yeah he's
got common knowledge this off season and
the weirdness of all of it and the
uncertainty of all of it is not going to
affect nick foles but you know hey
listen we talk about falls and trubisky
and all that and that's great uh but at
the same time you know matt nakey is
going to have to conform too you know
his offense his scheme the nfl caught on
to it last year it is not an impressive
scheme it lacks creativity you know
there's nothing special about it when
you break it down he needs to you know
up his game a little bit too to help the
quarterback succeed now you know how
much is that him holding things back
because maybe he doesn't feel mitch
trubisky's you know handling it able to
handle the full load of the offense i
don't know you know i hear rumors that
that is part of the issue but either way
i don't like the way it's looked at
offense the last few years and not that
necessarily that i was in love with it
the year before when they went to the
playoffs either of course they got to
the playoffs because they were a
defensive football team so uh there
there's issues there all together at the
quarterback position and i certainly
would think nick foles is the leader in
the club clubhouse as we sit here right
now
i remember someone being very salty
throughout the 2018 season because of
matt and eggy's comments about your
defense and being able to use more of it
with mitchell trubisky but look that's
the reality and that's why hey if ryan
pace wants to get the most out of
mitchell trubisky
maybe you hire a different coach than
matt nagy because naggy's eventually
going to want to go in a different
direction if trubisky doesn't fit what
neggie's trying to do now look they got
to the playoffs together in 2018 didn't
work last year we'll see how it plays
out this year and the lack of an
offseason program not as much of a
factor because foles knows the system
and we'll be ready to go day one and the
other beauty of of foals and then we're
going to take a break chris but if he
loses somehow the starting job to mitch
trubisky he's not going to sulk he's not
going to mope he's not going to get a
voodoo doll and start jamming you know
pins into the kneecaps of mitchell
trubisky he will support him as best he
can because he's been there he's done
that and he's done his best work coming
off the bench as a back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports